اسمي مارينا خان وأقوم بتصميم
الملابس والمجوهرات الأفغانية وأنا
مقيم في المملكة المتحدة وأريد
الترويج للجمال والثقافة الأفغانية نوعًا ما
وإبعادها عن الطريقة التي
يروج بها الغرب لذلك أعتقد أنه إذا نظرت إلى
التصاميم  إنها فريدة من نوعها للغاية، يمكنك معرفة
أنها من أفغانستان، والخرز،
والأعمال اليدوية، والألوان، والأشكال،
وأفغانستان متنوعة جدًا، فهي ليست مجرد
قطعة واحدة من الملابس، فلدينا العديد من
القبائل،
كل قطعة فريدة من نوعها لتروق لكل
قبيلة مختلفة وداخل أفغانستان
السترة التي هي عليها  ارتداء هذا هو
عمل الرصاص المنطقي وهذا يشبه إلى حد كبير
زخارف الزهور والألوان الزاهية إذا
نظرت إليها من الخلف
والأمام وهي جميع أنواع المجوهرات المصنوعة يدويًا
والعمل اليدوي، هذه المجوهرات ذات
شكل الوجه الثقيل متعدد الألوان مع
وجوه نجمة القمر  و pom-poms تشبه بشكل أساسي
قبيلة بلاكستون
هذه القطعة الرأسية هذه من
قبيلة الهزارة لذا فهي تحتوي على مقطع لفظي وهي
مميزة جدًا عن القبائل الأخرى
ولها دوافع وعمل الخط الفضي
وأجراس متصلة بالأسفل
وبعد ذلك  كلما اقتربنا من القلب كان الأمر
أكثر تميزًا ومن
أسلوب التاكمان فهو أشبه بالعملات المعدنية والأصداف
عندما بدأت لأول مرة كنت من
أوائل الأشخاص الذين بدأوا بالفعل مثل
بيع الملابس والمجوهرات الأفغانية
لم يكن لدي أي قدوة لدي  "ليس
لدي أي شخص أتطلع إليه ولكني أشعر
اليوم أن هناك الكثير من النساء
يقمن بما أفعله لأنهن رأوا
ما فعلته والآن يمكنني أن أكون ذلك المرشد
الذي لم يكن لدي، كان لدينا
رجال في المقام الأول  الخطوط الأمامية
وكان من الصعب جدًا الوصول إلى
النساء ولأطول وقت، ما
أردته هو أنني أردت أن يذهب المال مباشرة
إلى النساء حتى يمكن منحهن
المال مقابل عملهن الشاق مقابل وقتهن وجهدهن
الذي يستحقنه تمامًا
في كثير من الأحيان يتم تصوير النساء على
أنهن عاجزات وضعيفات، وقد لا يكون لديهن
المصادر التي قد لا يتمكنن من الوصول إليها،
وهذا هو المكان الذي أتيت إليه، وأريد أن
أمنحهن إمكانية الوصول إلى حيث
يمكن أن يعرفن أن لديهن نوعًا من الرحلة على
الطريق.  لكنني أشعر أنهن أكثر
مرونة من أي امرأة أخرى لأنهن
يبذلن قصارى جهدهن بما لديهن،
وإذا نظرت إلى
العمل الشاق الذي تقومين به، فاصنعي العمل الذي
يحاولون القيام به مع الأخذ في الاعتبار
البيئة التي يعيشون فيها.  نحن موجودون وكيف
تأثروا بالفقر وطول عمر
الحرب وكيف
أثرت على العائلات جيلًا
بعد جيل، إنهم يبذلون أقصى ما في وسعهم
من هذين الاثنين،
أود أن أقول إنك تعلم أنهم يبقونهم مستمرين
في ما  أنت تفعل، أنا
أؤمن بأحلامك، اتبع
أحلامك ولا يعيقك ما
يقوله الآخرون لك، أنت تعلم أن تؤمن بنفسك،
تحلى بهذا الأمل، وإذا كنت في
رحلة فسوف تصل أخيرًا إلى هناك
[موسيقى]
أجنبية